good afternoon and welcome to the
National Press Club my name is Richard
Ryan and I am senior Washington
correspondent for the Detroit News and
president of the National Press Club I
would like to welcome Club members and
their guests in the audience today and
those of you who are watching on c-span
are listening to this program on
National Public Radio the video archive
of today's luncheon is provided by
connect to live and is available to the
National Press Club website at NPC press
org National Press Club luncheons are
also carried live by many sites on the
world wide web Press Club members may
also access transcripts of our luncheons
at our website non-members may purchase
transcripts audio and videotapes by
calling one eighty eight three four
three one nine four zero before
introducing our head table I would like
to remind our members of upcoming
speakers on Thursday March 29th former
senator Sam Nunn will speak on the new
challenges facing US national security
on Tuesday April 3rd ted forstman senior
partner of forstman and little and
chairman and CEO of parents in charge
will be our guest and on Tuesday April
the 10th Joel Klein former assistant
attorney general for the Antitrust
Division the US Department of Justice
will be our guest if you have any
questions for our speaker and I trust
that you will please write them on the
cards that are provided at your table
and send them up to me and I will ask as
many as time permits I now like to
introduce our head table guests and ask
them to stand briefly when their names
are called but please hold your applause
until everyone has been introduced from
your right and my left we have Joseph
Layton former deputy White House press
spokesman one of several jobs in the
government Joe has held John Donnelly
editor of Defense Week and a member of
the National Press Club Board of
Governors Betty called do Curt executive
retired executive producer
of Meet the Press dinah line wand a
national reporter for USA Today Pat
Mitchell president and CEO of the Public
Broadcasting System robert Coonrod
president and CEO of the Corporation for
Public Broadcasting and Judith Davidson
Moyers wife of our speaker and as the
president of their corporation his boss
Frank aquifer former president of the
National Press Club and chairman of the
speaker's committee and skipping over
our speaker for a moment Ischia Mohammad
panelist of WH UT TVs evening exchange
weekly news analysis and White House
correspondent for final call newspaper
and the speaker's committee member who
organized today's luncheon Thank You s
gia Tina Tate director of the house and
radio TV gallery Bonnie Erbe a host of
the PBS program to the contrary mark
Plotkin political commentator for wamu
FM and Larry zanuck director of the US
Senate radio and TV gallery
in recent years we have seen an
increasing migration of journalists into
politics and politicians into journalism
our guest today bill moyers was a
pioneer in this transition he was the
first politician to make the switch from
politics to journalism after more than
four years in the White House as special
assistant and then press secretary for
President Lyndon V Johnson mr. Moyers
went first to Newsday as publisher
before establishing a career in
broadcasting that has earned him
practically every award and accolade
available his accomplishments are
legendary as a broadcast journalist mr.
Moyer has won more than 30 Emmy Awards
for excellence he also has received the
George Foster Peabody Award the Alfred I
DuPont Columbia University gold baton
award among many others for the more
than 200 hours of programming he has
produced for public affairs television
his independent production company a
survey of television critics by
television quarterly the Official
Journal of the National Academy of
Television Arts and Sciences place mr.
Moyers among the top 10 journalists who
have had the most significant influence
on television news mr. Moyers is
considered the thinking man's pundit
even has proof the International
Conference on thinking an annual
gathering of scholars and researchers
dedicated to improving critical and
creative thinking recently honored him
as a broadcaster they said and I quote
his contributions to public awareness of
the value and processes of thinking
spanned multiple areas helping the
American public understand how we think
now that's something to think about
born in yoga Oklahoma Bill Moyers not
William but bill grew up in Marshall
Texas he was reminisced of his hometown
and childhood he said it was a wonderful
place to be poor if you had to be poor
it was a genteel poverty in which people
knew who you were and kind of looked
after you by the age of 15
was working as a cub reporter on his
local newspaper the Marshall news
messenger in 1954 they worked on Lyndon
Johnson Senate campaign and then at mr.
Johnson's urging transferred from North
Texas State College to the University of
Texas at Austin where he majored in
journalism and worked at the Johnson's
family's television station he graduated
from the University of Texas in 1956 and
went on to earn a Bachelor of Divinity
degree at Southwestern Baptist
Theological Seminary but instead of
becoming a Baptist preacher mr. Moyers
joined the Kennedy Johnson campaign in
1960 as Lyndon Johnson's personal
assistant after Kennedy's election he
was appointed associate director of
public affairs at the Peace Corps and
later became its deputy director and
then as a special assistant to mr.
Johnson mr. Moyers help guide the
president's Great Society program
through Congress most recently mr.
Moyers has produced an upcoming
investigative report called trade
secrets which will air on PBS and March
26 this news making expose will
disseminate how the chemical industry
has used its money power and influence
to protect its own financial interests
despite the danger of its practices to
public health trade secrets is the
latest in a series of Moyers reports
that have examined the impact of
corporate lobbying on democracy the show
is also certain to be controversial as
evidenced by Washington Post story today
claiming chemical industry officials
were not interviewed for the show today
Bill Moyers gives us a peek inside the
combined world of politics and
journalism in his address which he has
entitled things I would have told
Stephanopoulos if only he had asked
please join me in welcoming Bill Moyers
to the National Press Club
don't think of it thank you for that
generous introduction hi my name is Bill
and I'm a recovering unimpeachable
source I understand
unimpeachable source is now an oxymoron
in Washington as is McCain Republican
our Democratic Party but once upon a
time in another millennium the 1960s I
was one deep backgrounders and
unattributable tips were my drugs of
choice they could deliver a high as
exhilarating as an ecstasy pill at a
rave party but they could also produce a
hangover as depressing as Tom DeLay
smile or a joke by Al Gore just go to
Austin and listen to me on those tapes
LBJ secretly recorded that's the sound
of a young man getting high without
inhaling I swore off 34 years ago and
I'm here to tell you that it hasn't been
easy some of the guys carter clinton
gore wouldn't let me forget my former
life they kept asking me to come back to
the old neighborhood for one more blast
now when you're addicted you know that
the brain never forgets that first hi
you're never far from a relapse i can't
even watch west wing without breaking
into a sweat
a c-span briefing by harry Fleischman
since me right to the edge and the
craving really goes into overdrive at
the side of beer on Jack Germans tie are
the smell of champagne and salami on Bob
Novak's breath are the smoothing purr of
a sam donaldson question but I know that
just one shot or as Clinton would say
one snort and I could wind up like my
friend gergan in and out of revolving
doors and needing to go in the NewsHour
for a fixed between presidents frankly I
wouldn't have made it all these years
without our support group of former
born-again journalists spin-doctors
anonymous we call ourselves believe me
it takes more than 12 steps away from
the old sauce before you can really get
it out of your system and it's very
reassuring to sit in a circle listening
to other people's stories of hitting
bottom of course bill sapphire can make
a nuisance of himself always correcting
our usage then referring to his own
political dictionary as an authoritative
inside source and then insisting on
opening every meeting by reading from
the big book the Webster's international
dictionary and Sam script and Latin and
Pat Buchanan or can he be a bore
bragging about all he does how you can
do the all 12 steps every four years on
his right foot hopping backwards Joe
Lockwood came to his first meeting the
day after Clinton left the White House
poor Joe was feeling very humble he just
kept shaking his head and muttering
pardon me pardon me pardon me
Tim Russert looked up and said pardon
you that's rich
and immediately Chris Matthews started
shouting
even the serenity prayer can start Chris
Matthews shouting I'll never forget the
first time Stephanopoulos joined the
group he almost broke into tears when we
assured him it was okay for him now to
acknowledge a higher power than Hillary
you would have thought all the silver
teaspoons had fallen out of his coat
pocket I showed him the hallway pass
that Lyndon made us use every time we
needed to go to the bathroom it required
his signature as everyone knows George
is clearly in recovery and his admission
and his addiction is in deep remission
he's been moving from pundit re2 analyst
and reporter just one very short well
very long election George recently told
brill's content that he's using my
recovery as the model for his own
sobriety I have to admit that I'm
honored after all when I was press
secretary our credibility was so bad Joe
we couldn't believe our own leaks
then I mentioned that we actually won
the Vietnam War I suppose Jorge figures
that if I can recover into journalism
anybody can but I'm actually not here to
talk about my time in the White House I
haven't talked much about it at all
although I do plan to write about it
someday soon during the last three and a
half decades I've learned that the job
of trying to tell the truth about the
people whose job it is to hide the truth
is almost as complicated and difficult
as trying to hide it in the first place
unless you're willing to fight and re
fight the same battles until you go blue
in the face unless you're willing to
drive the people you work with nuts over
every last detail to make it certain you
got it right and unless you're willing
to take hit after unfair hit accusing
you of a bias or these days even of a
point of view there's no use even trying
you have to love it and I do love it
I've always loved it the White House was
an aberration for me
journalism is what I wanted to do since
I was a kid as Dick said 50 years ago
actually on my 16th birthday I went to
work at the Marshall news messenger the
daily newspaper in a small Texas town
seemed the best place in the world to be
a cub reporter it was small enough to
navigate but big enough to keep me busy
happy and learning something new every
day
I was lucky when I went to work there
some of the old-timers were out sick or
on vacation and I got assigned to cover
the housewives rebellion 15 women in
Marshall refused to pay the Social
Security withholding tax for their
domestic workers the rebels argued that
social security was unconstitutional
that imposing it was taxation without
representation and that here's my
favorite part
requiring us to collect the tax is no
different from acquiring us to collect
the garbage they hired themselves a
lawyer Martin dies the ex-congressman
best known or worst known for his work
as head of a House Committee on
unamerican activities in the 1930s and
40s
eventually the women wound up paying the
tax while
their noses the stories that I wrote for
the news messenger were picked up and
moved on The Associated Press wire one
day after it was all over the managing
editor called me over and pointed to the
ap ticker beside his desk moving across
the wire at that very moment was a
notice to editors citing one bill moyers
and the news messenger for the reporting
we had done on the rebellion I was
hooked I was caught two years later as
the introduction said as a sophomore I
decided I wanted to become a political
journalist and figured experience in
Washington would help me learn the ropes
I wrote a man I had never met out of the
blue a United States Senator named
Lyndon Johnson and asked him for a
summer job lucky again I got it by
summer's end LBJ and Lady Bird had
offered me a job on their television
station in Austin for $100 a week which
enabled Judith and me to marry and
finished the University of Texas we were
the first station in Texas by the way to
buy a red station wagon and christen it
what else
Red Rover I've wheeled around town in
style broadcasting from accidents and
crime scenes and the state legislature
which of course was the biggest crime
scene in Austin looking back on all that
followed and seeing these young
journalists here today looking back on
all that follows seminary the Peace
Corps the White House Newsday PBS CBS
and PBS again I often think of what
Joseph Elif L the executive editor of
the New York Times told some aspiring
young journalists you can never know how
a life in journalism will turn out he
said decide that you want to be a
scholar a lawyer or a doctor and your
path to the grave is pretty well laid
out before you decide that you want to
enter our rather less reputable line of
work and you set out on a route that can
sometimes seem to be nothing but
diversions switchbacks and a life of
surprises with the constant temptation
to keep reinventing yourself and so I
have it took me a while after the White
House
to learn that what's important in
journalism is not how close you are to
power but how close you are to reality
journalism took me to reality famine in
Africa war in Central America to the
bedside of the dying to the delivery
rooms of new life
journalism took me into the complex
intricate world of inner-city families
in Newark and to working-class families
in Frank's Milwaukee struggling to
survive the good times I was paid richly
as a CBS News analyst put in my two
cents worth on just about anything that
happened on that day working on
documentaries I've explored everything
from the power of money and politics to
how to make a poem from the mystery of
key to the miracle of how a former slave
trader wrote to him amazing grace my
life in journalism has been a continuing
course in adult education my own and I
haven't had to grow up and get a day job
don't tell me how lucky I am believe me
I know it we have to market our programs
under one name and so mine is the one
that makes it to the Billboard but the
truth is while I am enormous ly proud of
the work our team at public affairs
television has produced over the course
of the last 15 years I can claim credit
for only a small part of whatever it is
that makes it distinctive my single
greatest piece of good fortune in
television has been the fact that my
chief talent seems to be four
collaborators who are often braised
braver and wiser than I am first and
last of course is my wife of 47 years my
partner my executive producer the
president of our company
Judith Moyers Dick Judith has the title
she didn't need the title to hold the
power of my boss
and and judy dr. Rolph who joined us 15
years ago practically out of Yale and
has passed through fire and storm
producing dozens of major projects and
three marvelous sons sherry Jones is
sitting right back there she's a
remarkable journalist the only
independent producer I know of in
Washington who will still take on the
really tough documentaries about power
and policy we've been collaborating for
off and on for a quarter of a century we
did the very first documentary ever
about political action committees I can
still see the final scene in that film
yard after yard after yard after yard of
computer printout listing campaign
contributions to members of Congress
unfurl like toilet paper stretching all
the way across the capitol grounds that
one infuriated Bob just about everybody
in Congress including the best friends
of public television up there but PBS
CBS CPB took the heat and PBS didn't
melt when sherry and I reported the
truth behind the news of the iran-contra
scandal for a frontline documentary
called high crimes and misdemeanors the
right-wing Taliban in town went running
to the ayatollahs in Congress who
decried the fact that public television
was committing Horrors journalism the
Clinton White House didn't like it in
fact when I ran into the president by
coincidence at a subsequent meeting he
stood behind someone and reached out and
shook my hand and said nothing because
the White House didn't like it a bit
when sherry and I reported Washington's
other scandal about the Democrats
unbridled and illegal fundraising
practices during the 1996 election those
programs give me the opportunity to pay
tribute to another circle of supporters
without whom I would have just have been
another voice in the wilderness
if PBS didn't flinch neither did my
corporate underwriter for 10 years now
mutual of America life insurance company
the president and chief executive
officer of mutual was here a little
earlier Tom Moran and I'm glad he came
because I want to salute a man whose
company believes that encouraging
dialogue and discussion is the spirit of
America who believes that independent
journalism is good for democracy and
what's good for democracy is good for
mutual of America when Tom successor
bill Flynn who was then chairman and Tom
came to me ten years ago and said on
their own initiative we want to be your
underwriter in public broadcasting I
said look I'm a journalist I don't get
good ratings what I get is trouble they
said that's alright before mutual came
along I had three I lost at least three
corporate underwriters who were happy as
long as we didn't make anyone else
unhappy losing your underwriting in
public broadcasting I guess in anything
will keep the yellow light of caution
flickering in a journalist unconscious
before mutual came along and I kicked
myself for this I sometimes avoided even
writing a proposal on a controversial
subject to potential underwriters
because I had told myself convinced
myself nah not a chance thanks to the
camaraderie and courage of Tom Moran and
mutual of America the yellow light
flickers no more this
this confluence of good fortune and good
company has made it possible for us to
do programs that the network's they are
not contemplated with the exception of
Nightline I should have warned
Stephanopoulos about all this commercial
television ain't what it used to be when
I was fortunate enough to be chief
correspondent for CBS reports part of
the problem of course is Ray is ratings
it's not easy as John Dewey said to
interest the public in the public
interest for all his experience in
government George has come to
broadcasting when public policy is no
longer a crucial beat in fact I'd say
that apart from the obvious changes in
technology the biggest change in my 30
years in broadcasting has been the shift
of content of from news about government
to consumer driven information and
celebrity features the project for
excellence in journalism conducted a
study of the front pages of the New York
Times and the Los Angeles Times the
nightly news programs of ABC CBS and NBC
and Time and Newsweek they found that
from 1977 to 1997 the number of stories
about government dropped from one in
three to one in five while the number of
stories about celebrities rose from one
in 50 stories to one in every fourteen
does it matter well as we learned in the
60s but seem to have forgotten
government is about who wins and who
loses in this vast Bazaar of democracy
government can send us to war pick our
pockets slap us in jail run a highway
through our garden look the other way as
polluters do their dirty work and take
care of the people who are already well
taken care of at the expense of those
who can't afford lawyers or lobbyists or
have time for vigilance it matters who's
pulling the strings in all Washington is
about I tell young journalists is
pulling the strings follow the money
follow the stream you always get the
story it also matters who defines the
news and decides what to cover it
matters whether we're over at the puffy
combs try
checking out what Jennifer Lopez was
wearing the night she ditched him or
whether we're on the hill seeing who's
riding the new bankruptcy law who's
overturning workplace safety rules who's
buying back the standards for allowable
levels of arsenic in our drinking water
I need to declare a bias here it's true
that I worked for two Democratic
presidents John Kennedy and Lyndon
Johnson both of whom both of whom I was
proud to serve but I did more so more
for reasons of opportunity than ideology
my worldview was really shaped by
Theodore Roosevelt whom of course I
didn't know but about whom I simply
cannot read enough Teddy Roosevelt and
the muckrakers of his day whom he loved
although they persecuted him sometimes
Teddy Roosevelt got it right about power
in America Roosevelt thought the central
fact of his era was that economic power
had become so centralized and so
dominant it could chew up democracy and
spit it out the power of corporations he
said had to be balanced in the interest
of the general public otherwise America
would undergo a class war the rich would
win and we wouldn't recognize our
country anymore
shades of DejaVu here we are again big
money and big business corporations and
commerce are the undisputed overlords of
politics and government the White House
Congress and increasingly the judiciary
reflect their interests there are times
when I think we have a government run by
remote control from the US Chamber of
Commerce the National Association of
Manufacturers and the American Petroleum
Institute the GOP stands once again for
the guardians of privilege and a
democratic party but who's afraid of an
oxymoron what's the role of journalism
in all this the founders of our nation
were pretty explicit on this point the
First Amendment is there for a reason is
needed to keep our leaders honest and
the armed the powerless with the
information they need to protect
themselves against the tyranny of the
powerful whether that tyranny is
political or commercial at least that's
my bias a college student once asked the
veteran reporter Richard Reeves what's
your definition of real news and Richard
Reeves answered the news you and I need
to keep our freedoms Senator John McCain
echoed this and an interview I did with
him a couple of years ago for a
documentary called free speech for sale
a documentary by the way has been used
by many public television stations in
pledge week
proving that you can get a public to
respond to support public broadcasting
with tough journalism even more so
sometimes than you can with the
Riverdance this documentary was about
the Telecommunications Act of 1996 when
some of America's most powerful
corporations were picking the taxpayers
pockets of 70 billion dollars that's the
estimated value of the digital spectrum
that Congress was giving away to the big
media conglomerates Senator McCain said
on the floor of the Senate during that
debate quote the average American does
not know what digital spectrum is they
just don't know but here in Washington
their assets that they own were being
given away and the coverage was
minuscule you will not see this story on
any television or hear it on any
broadcast because it directly affects
them McCain said sure enough the
Telecommunications Act was introduced
around May of 1995 and was finally
passed in early February of 1996 during
those nine months the three major
network new shows aired a sum total of
only 19 minutes about the legislation
and none of the 19 minutes included a
single mention of the debate over
whether the broadcasters should pay for
the digital spectrum the founders did
not reckon on the rise of mega media did
not count on
huge private corporations private
corporations that would own not only the
means of journalism but vast swaths of
the territory journalists should be
covering during the interview I asked
McCain if we have to rely on the media
to at least analyze what the
corporation's are doing and the media
don't do that how do we level the
playing field any answer I don't know
bill I don't know the problem is a real
one and we journalists know it according
to another recent study done by the Pew
Research Center for the people and the
press for the Columbia Journalism Review
more than a quarter of us more than a
quarter of us journalists said that we
had avoided at some point pursuing some
newsworthy story that might conflict
with the financial interest of their
news organizations or advertisers and
many thought that complexity or lack of
audience appeal causes newsworthy
stories not to be pursued in the first
place I saw one study recently that as
the media mergers accelerated in the
early 1990s coverage of crime on the
major networks went up while coverage of
serious issues including the environment
and education went down I don't mean to
suggest that there was a golden age of
journalism I told you earlier about
covering the housewives rebellion and
Marshall what I didn't tell you is that
it was the White House wives who made
news with their boycott of Social
Security not the domestic workers
themselves they were black I wasn't sent
to interview them it didn't occur to me
that I should have been sent to
interview them while Marshall was 50%
white and 50% black the official view of
reality the official view of reality was
that only white people made news Oh a
small account of black sports churches
or service clubs occasionally made the
paper
but what blacks felt and thought never
did if blacks got into the paper at all
it was the same way they got into the
movies through the side door I thought
about this on a recent trip Judith and I
made to Ireland we came across there at
the story of an Irish king named conjul
who ruled in the early 7th century
conjul was an ambitious fella and even
after he'd been attacked by a swarm of
bees that stung him nearly blonde he
succeeded in becoming the / king of his
clan where he became known as conjure
Kesh which means conjul the half blind
or conjul the squinty
squinting that sounds something like the
journalism we practiced in that little
town 50 years ago we squinted and when
it came to seeing the whole community we
were half blind I could kick myself for
the hath blindness that has afflicted me
throughout the years from the times at
the White House when I admonished
journalists for going beyond the
official view of reality in Vietnam to
the times I have left the flickering
yellow light turned red in my own mind
on worthy journalistic projects maybe
it's because I'm a southerner and
because I served in the White House that
this affliction haunts me there's a line
in Tom Stoppard's play night and day
when one of the characters a news
photographer says people do terrible
things to each other but it's worse in
places where everybody's kept in the
dark the truth about slavery was driven
from our pulpits from our newsrooms in
our classrooms and it took the Civil War
to bring the truth home then the truth
about Jim Crow was sense of - and it
took another hundred years to produce
the justice that should have followed
Appomattox in the white house across the
street in the 60s we circle the wagons
we grew intolerant of news that didn't
make us comfortable and if we could we
would have declared illegal the sting of
the bee so I sympathize with my friends
in commercial broadcasting who don't
cover the ocean they're swimming in but
I don't envy them
having all those resources all that
money without the freedom to use them to
do the kind of stories that are begging
to be done seems to me more of a curse
than a blessing like that line from
Bruce Springsteen eating caviar and dirt
but I'm not here to scold my colleagues
at the network's not to hold myself up
as some sort of beacon I've made my own
compromises as I said and benefited from
the special circumstances of my own good
luck but the fact that I have been so
lucky and both opportunity and
colleagues shows that it can be done all
that's required is for journalists to
act like journalists and their sponsors
public or private to back them up when
the going gets a little rough because
when you're dealing with powerful
interest be they in government or
private industry and bringing to light
what has been hidden the going
inevitably gets a little rough we didn't
play beanbag back in the Johnson
administration and it's hardly a kinder
gentler world for journalism out there
today if it weren't for the strong
support I served under five public
television presidents Pat Mitchell is
the latest and none has had a firmer
backbone Bob Coonrod heads the
Corporation for Public Broadcasting he's
our heat shield and he really takes it
but they've stood with us let me just
give you a couple of examples in closing
of what I mean why this battle is
never-ending some years ago my colleague
Marty qyn one of the great investigative
journalists of producers of our time
came to me with a report he'd heard of
efforts by the agricultural chemical
industry to delay and dilute an
important study by the National Academy
of Sciences on the effects of pesticide
residues on children david fanning a
frontline joined us as an ally and we
set out about doing a documentary four
to six weeks before we were finished the
industry contained a obtained a
purloined copy of the rough script and
mounted a sophisticated and expensive
campaign to discredit the doc
mentoree before it air they flooded
television reviewers and the editorial
pages of newspapers with propaganda a
Washington Post columnist took a dig at
the broadcast on the morning of the day
and aired without ever having seen it
and later admitted to me personally when
we had a drink in this building that the
DA the dig had been supplied by a top
lobbyist in town public television
stations were hit with an avalanche of
disinformation and with demands that PBS
quote obey the law such as the First
Amendment some station that managers
were so unnerved they protested the
documentary with letters that had been
prepared by industry several station
managers later wrote me in their own
words and in their over their own
signature apologizing for having been
suckered but here's what most perplexed
us eight days before the broadcast aired
the American Cancer Society a fine
organization that in no way figured in
our documentary sent to its 3,000 local
chapters a critique of the unfinished
documentary claiming wrongly that it
exaggerated the hazards that struck us
as odd why was such a reputable
organization taking the unusual step of
criticizing a documentary it hadn't seen
that hadn't aired and didn't claim what
the society alleged well an enterprising
reporter in town named Sheila Caplan
later looked into this question for
legal times which headlined her story
quote Porter Novelli plays all sides it
turns out that the porter novelli public
relations firm which had worked for
several chemical companies also did pro
bono work for the American Cancer
Society Sheila Kaplan found that the
firm was able to cash in some of the
goodwill from that pro bono work to
persuade the staff the communication
staff of the American Cancer Society to
distribute some harsh talking points
about our documentary that had been
supplied by but not attributed to Porter
Novelli other used the Society's good
name to discredit the documentary
including the right wing polemicist here
in town Reed Irvine who published a
screed against quote junk science on PBS
and call
in Congress to pull the plug on public
television again PBS stood firm again
the report air the journalism held up in
contrast to the disinformation about it
and the National Academy of Science was
liberated finally to release the report
the industry had tried to [ __ ] with
propaganda
none of us this should have surprised us
this is the industry that thirty years
earlier had mounted a blitzkrieg
designed to destroy Rachel Carson's
credibility as soon as The New Yorker
published the first of her three-part
condensed ation of Silent Spring Rachel
Carson was accused of a communist plot
to [ __ ] American industry one
chemical company threatened to sue
Carson and her publishers if the book
was released others threatened to
withhold advertising from garden
magazines and weekly supplements if they
published favorable reviews of silent
spraying the industry invested millions
of dollars in public relations that paid
off in support articles from the New
York Times Time Sports Illustrated and
Reader's Digest then like the American
Cancer Society in our time the American
Medical Association was look about the
industry the AMA criticized Carson's
book as a serious threat to the
continued supply of wholesome nutritious
food Rachel Carson was dying of cancer
at the time but events totally
vindicated her and within a year 40
state legislators had passed regulations
concerning pesticides but there's always
the next round next Monday PBS were
broadcast our documentary on trade
secrets it's a two-hour investigative
based on the chemical industries own
archives own lot documents that make
clear in the industry's own words what
the industry didn't tell us about cat
toxic chemicals why they didn't tell us
and why we still don't know what we have
the right to know these internal
industry documents are fact they exist
they're not a matter of opinion or point
of view they state what the industry
knew when they knew it and what they
decided to do
but their value is not just historic or
journalistic they deal with one of the
big stories of our time over the past 50
years you and I have lived through the
chemical revolution it's brought us many
blessings better living through
chemistry is true but it's also brought
some results we didn't ask for tens of
thousands of synthetic chemicals have
been put into products on the market
into the environment and into our bodies
pesticides pollutants from in the
industry and waste chemicals found in
ordinary industrial household products
simply by being alive by eating
breathing drinking going to school or
work every one of you in this room
carries traces of industrial chemicals
in your bloodstream so does every
American alive today this we know but
very little is known about the health
effects this combination of chemicals
may be having on us just yesterday the
Centers for Disease Control issued the
first of several rounds of an
investigation they're doing into these
traces of chemicals into our body for
the purposes of our broadcast I took
part in a test of my own chemical body
burden at the Mount Sinai Hospital in
New York which is one of the pioneers in
public and community health you'll see
the results of that test next Monday
night I don't want to scoop myself but I
will tell you that the tests found a mix
of 31 PCBs in my body 13 dioxins and 40
other varieties of synthetic or
industrial chemicals you'll hear the
research director tell me that only one
of these chemicals led which has been
around since the beginning of time only
one of these chemicals would have been
in my grandfather's or my grandmother's
body because this is too recent a
phenomenon I asked him if that aged 66 I
should be worrying and he said probably
not but if you were a 21 year old
pregnant woman the story could be
different the public policy implications
of this documentary next week are
profound the documents remember
documents that neither we or the public
we journalists nor the public were ever
supposed to see reveal just how the
industry set out to control the reg
Nitori system that was supposed to
provide the American people with
oversight and protection but that's an
illusion we live today under a
regulatory system designed by the
industry itself and the truth is if the
public the media independent scientists
and government regulators had known what
the industry knew about the risk of its
products when the industry knew it
America's laws and regulations governing
chemical manufacturing would be far more
protective of human health than they are
today but the industry didn't want us to
know that's the message of the
documentary that's the story I wish I
could tell you I came upon this story
myself I didn't Jim Morris now of US
News and World Report got wind of them
when he was at the Houston Chronicle and
wrote about some aspects of the severe
sting universe and a series called in
strictest confidence the environmental
working group has been looking into them
as well but it took the indefatigable
sherry Jones and her team back at this
table to burrow into thousands upon
thousands hundreds of thousands of
documents to find the scarlet thread
running across almost half a century
when she realized the magnitude of what
she had undertaken which she realized
she needed allies and funding she came
to see Judith and me this was almost two
years ago and our collaboration began we
designed months ago the broadcast to
include a half-hour discussion of the
issues raised by our documented
documents in our reporting we invited
industry representatives to participate
and they have now accepted Terry OC
who's vice president of the American
Chemistry Council is here today Terry
and I've talked several times over the
past month again just yesterday he
assured me that contrary to rumors the
chemical industry was not pressuring
stations to reject the broadcast I
believed him
but I wasn't sure for a while as I told
Terry OC remember my experience eight
years ago the first person to contact us
from the industry was a public relations
firm here in Washington note
for hiring private detectives former CIA
FBI and drug enforcement officers to do
its investigations the founder of the
company has on the record in the
Washington Post saying that sometimes
corporations need to resort to
unconventional resources and some of
those resources this is a direct quote
include using deceit quote I tell my
clients that if you live by the sword
you may die by the sword but if you live
by the olive branch you still may die by
the sword
for PBS it's a Damocles sword would you
believe that the single biggest
recipient of campaign contributions from
the chemical industry over the past 20
years in the house is the very member of
Congress whose committee has
responsibility for Public Broadcasting's
appropriations were pat she left Ted
Turner for this what do you say Pat this
is nothing compared to working for Ted
Turner she says what would I have told
Stephanopoulos if he had asked I would
have told him that in crossing-over he
was coming to a journalist utopia in
many parts of the world assassins have
learned they can kill reporters with
impunity journalists are hunted down and
murdered because of their reporting 34
died in Colombia over the last decade
alone here well Don Hewitt at 60 minutes
said to me recently that the 90s were a
terrible time for American journalism
but a wonderful time for American
journalists why I said because we're
living like Jack Welch he said perhaps
that's why we don't ask hard questions
of Jack Welch I don't want to claim too
much for our craft but I don't want to
claim too little either the late Martha
Gellhorn spent half a century observing
war and politicians and journalists too
by the end she lost her faith that
journalism could by itself changed the
world but she had found a different sort
of comfort its shapes human destiny she
said of our
left but makes no last decision victory
and defeat
Argo passing moments for journalists
journalism is a means she said and I now
think that the act of keeping the record
straight
is valuable enough itself serious
careful honest journalism she said is
essential not because it is a guiding
light but because it is a form of
honorable behavior involving the
reporter and the reader thank you
you can't get off so easy you have to
get back up here I can see you're still
an editor that I mentioned you were 15
when you started at the paper and you
corrected me to say you were 16 you
haven't lost the touch I have here a
number of questions that deal with the
chemical program as you can well be
aware of they all asked why you decided
to exclude the industry shouldn't they
have been included do you feel that that
was wrong now do you have regrets and do
you think newspapers might have handled
that story differently since they're
instructed to put the opposing view up
high in the story that's Terry OC spin
he's a good he's good at his job I told
him that he said to me yesterday maybe
when when he does his next he gets his
next in review from his executives that
I'll put in a good word for him I will
he's very good at what he does but
that's not the truth
we didn't exclude the chemical industry
from our documentary we planned a
two-hour broadcast in which they would
have had will have they are coming to a
half hour one quarter of the broadcast
to deal with the issues raised our
reporting as I said the record is there
the documents are there it's the
documents that create the discussion
we'll have that discussion and we plan
that all along when you see the
documentary you'll see what I mean
why that's appropriate wow that's good
sound honest accurate journalism to
shape the broadcast so that there's half
an hour in which we discuss the issues
raised by reporting they will have more
time in that half hour than they would
have if I had interviewed them and if I
had interviewed them they would have
claimed that I didn't give them enough
of the interview and I had taken them
out of contact and then they would have
turned their advertising firm their
public relations firm loose on us here
just like the agricultural chemistry did
eight years ago I'm not a fool
they will have their moments and that
was intended the spin is they're not
included they're not included they're
not included they are included and
they've chosen to come and I'm glad
Teri's an honorable man work many years
at the Environmental Protection Agency
knows this field I'm looking for he says
he will be on the program I'm delighted
to be there dr. Phil Lander gun from
mount sinai will be there one of the
leading pediatricians in the in the in
the world we haven't decided which
environmentalists to invite yet and
terry hasn't told me until we talk to
more afternoon who will be the other
representative from the chemical
industry but i just want to put the rest
they will have their time as the pin in
the broadcast on edited terry asked me
yesterday will you tape and edit no will
you put us will you put a closing on it
no i'll just say good night and thank
you I don't believe we don't believe in
ambush in ambush journalism I
interviewed Jack Welch an hour and a
half last week for another documentary
we're doing on the on the environment he
told me about just recently being
ambushed here in in in Washington at an
event he's and I said why did you give
us so much time he said because I didn't
think you would ambush it you don't
survive very long thirty years in
particular and I live in fear that
others will harm public broadcasting for
something I do so I make sure that our
reporting is fair balanced and accurate
and that the other side has heard in the
broadcast that question and dealing with
finance a campaign finance and reform do
you consider that passage of the
mccain-feingold or or some similar
legislation critical to our political
system I the the important thing is to
get that to reduce the power of private
money over public policy look you live
in this city you don't need an outsider
a former insider to tell you what's
happened to politics the other big
changes money had politics has become an
arms race each side escalates I feel for
the politicians caught in this system
you might escalate escalate we wind up
having to spend all of our time raising
money in this you know let's it is it is
legal bribery if it's not another kind
of power it's it's killing our
democracy folks it's really killing our
democracy the spirit of it I don't know
if this bill is gonna come out with
anything that's really good or just more
of an illusion
the real answer in time the real answer
sooner in time is public funding for
democracy you know if we if anybody's
gone if I believe if if anybody is going
to own the politicians we should not the
chemical industry not the manufacturers
industry not the environmental
organizations we shut the voters they
should be accountable to us the only way
to do that get public funding like Maine
Arizona Massachusetts have done in the
last two years with some help that I've
given them through a foundation that as
a citizen I I run I care about this
issue for my three grandchildren I don't
want them growing up in a society where
their civic worth is determined by their
net worth and that's what's happening
the rich have every right to buy more
cars more houses more vacations more
leisure but they don't have the right to
buy more democracy and they are and if
we don't change it then as Teddy
Roosevelt said we won't know this
country 20 years from now
before asking the last question we had a
short question and answer period today I
would like to present you with a couple
of things one is a certificate of
appreciation for your appearance here
today at the Press Club thank you and
the second is the Press Club mug that we
give to all our guests and usable for
almost anything
I sort of like to make this kind of a
two-part question
this goes back to your days as White
House press secretary this question just
asked on a scale of one to ten how would
you describe your credibility when you
were a White House spokesperson and then
at a second question you mentioned
before that you may be writing a book
about your period at the White House and
you certainly lived through and
experienced one of the most tumultuous
and interesting periods in our history
and when can we look forward to seeing
that book
well not for three or four years I'm as
I said I'm 66 I'm planning to retire
from from active public television at 70
and and the research is now being done
on it won't be an inside story it won't
be a kiss-and-tell we didn't kiss and
nobody had much to tell from that that
time but it will be an effort exactly as
you said I am really profoundly curious
now 40 years later about the
contradictions of that time it was a
great time to be an idealist and yet
look what happened it was a great time
to believe in that we were going to find
it there was no polls saying to a
poverty war there was there was no
corporate support a public demand for a
war on poverty it was a great time to be
in this city
to wanting to try to make this a better
country and then all kinds of things
happen most of which I don't even
understand and I want to just reflect on
it and try to see if I can put our time
and our experience in the White House in
some kind of context of the of the
sixties it'll be a modest
book and it'll be three or four years
before we can I can get it done if by
then my credibility went up and down at
first there was euphoria that LBJ had
brought in this young man who didn't
know enough not to tell the truth and
then who got in trouble for telling the
truth and
begin to try to do what everybody else
does
and then I got into trouble we have said
our credibility was so bad we couldn't
believe our leaks it went up and down as
the fortunes as the fortunes of the of
events on the hill the election when we
lost all those seats in in in in
Congress in 66 and then of course the
war the war is the great great puzzle
the great great puzzle even to those of
us who some of us who were there at the
time President was deeply conflicted
about it from the very beginning there's
a record that he called me very early in
64 before the campaign and I said you
ought to take a vacation he said I can't
tell you occasion I gotta stay and worry
about that goddamn war I said what war
the war in Vietnam I mean I don't
understand it forty years later I
haven't thought much about it because I
don't know what to think about it or
what to say about it but it'll be that
my credibility you know was up and down
I do want to say Terry that that that
I'm a documentarian I take too long to
tell the story and I take too long to
speech but I promise you you'll have
your time all 30 minutes of it next
Tuesday next Monday night
Thank You mr. Moyers and I'd like to
thank you all for coming today and I'd
like to recognize students from the
Annandale high school's ap journalism
class and students from Deborah Academy
in Denver Colorado who are visiting us
with with us here today and I'd also
like to thank National Press Club staff
members Melinda Cook Pat Nelson Joanne
boos Melanie Abdo Dermot and Howard
Rothman for organizing today's luncheon
also thanks to the NPC library for the
research and thank you we are journey